It was Stephen Fry,
I think,
who said a truth thing poorly expressed
is alive.
It's the theory that the language you
speak determines how you think it
affects how you see everything.
The point being that there is no thought
without expression,
no content without form,
that an idea,
however profound it feels to you,
does not really exist until you can
write it down or in some cases put it on
film to watch Disney Villeneuve's
arrival is to watch a film maker in
command of the language.
His ideas presuppose,
which is to say that he has a firm grasp
on craft.
I can't really tell you how soothing
this is for me as a film goer to feel
that I'm in the hands of someone who
knows why the film is constructed the
way it is.
So much of today's filmmaking is all
over the place,
to the point where the viewer has to
exert themselves more to compensate for
a lack of focus in this way.
I think arrival is the perfect response
to the bad movies.
We see so much of pretty much everything
they do,
wrong arrival dose,
right?
It is effective and impactful and it
does this by focusing on the very thing
that affects and impacts us language,
but I think arrival is just as concerned
with the language of film as it is with
written or spoken or alien language.
For example,
the first couple of scenes are kind of
like an enlarged experiment in the
coolest shop effect,
the phenomenon in which a viewer derives
meaning from two sequential shots that
hitchcock famously illustrated by
turning a kindly gentleman into a
pervert by replacing a single reverse
shot.
They'll move,
does the same thing in a rival,
but on the scene level.
The first scene is a montage of the
birth and young death of Amy Adams
starter.
The second scene is Adam's coming to
teach at her school on the day of the
aliens arrival and because of the
tragedy we witness in the first scene
and our assumption that the film's
timeline is linear.
We read Adam's disinterest here as
despondency and her general demeanor as
one of deep sadness and heartache.
It's not until we finished the film and
learn that the opening montage happens
after the events of the movie that we
understand Adams in the second scene was
merely a blank canvas that we attached,
meaning to
montage means the assembly of pieces of
film which moved in rapid succession
before the I create an idea
what separates Ville knew from many
other filmmakers is his ability to
generate ideas with cinematic craft.
Then on another level,
mingle those ideas collide and blend
them to create a higher order of
meaning.
What's the meaning,
for example,
that bill knew suggests with this
coolest job effect experiment perhaps
that the future can influence the past.
That's certainly a reasonable thing to
derive from this kind of experience in
the film.
In fact,
it's an idea that turns out to be the
key to the climax of arrival as Adam's
learns that the aliens are higher
dimensional beings that can see all of
time at once and uses that skill to
access future events to influence her
present,
but you could also read another meaning
from the same experience.
Namely that communication is limited by
perspective.
From our perspective at the beginning of
the film,
everything tells us that Adams is
grieving.
Only later did we learn that that wasn't
true.
It's to is a major theme of a rifle.
The limits of human communication are
reinforced and expanded upon in probe
throughout the film,
the limits of our biology of relying on
what our census report,
the limits imposed on us by our culture
or our own personalities.
Trust me,
you can understand communication and
still ended up staying in conversation
with the aliens.
Communication is literally imagined as a
screen,
a mediator that blurs intention.
Now screens can connect us.
They can also divide us and it's the
same with communication.
Communication is a link between two
parties,
but it's a link that often facilitates a
split
language is the foundation of
civilization use glue that holds people
together is the first weapon drawn into
conflict.
We are falling asleep.
I don't up people.
You know what I'm talking about.
I know you do.
What's important here is not that both
these readings are valid,
they are,
but that both have echoes elsewhere in
the film and echo off each other a
theme.
Once introduced isn't wasted,
the alien language is circular,
so the film is to the difficulty of
cooperation in the small group at the
Montana site,
echoes the difficulty of cooperation
between nations.
Louise's understanding of her
displacement in time happens
simultaneously with the audiences
realization that the events depicted
aren't linear,
non zero sum game.
Every theme is filtered through other
moments and characters and eventually
other themes until it starts to feel
like something solid.
You start to think what is the
relationship between language and time?
Maybe it's that the mind is not a thing,
but a process language happening in
time.
Just like film is communication
occurring in time.
You had noise in schools anymore.
A Muslim is video,
so much of arrival seems to be about the
possibility of meaning in film.
What is it?
Where does it come from?
I think Villeneuve imagines it as an
alien spacecraft,
mysterious,
obscure,
and expression that's not quite written
or spoken language and so always
difficult to decipher something when
born out of craft and character and
story is always hovering over the film.
It's always in the background scene from
different angles,
impossible to avoid.
Arrival isn't just a repudiation of bad
movies because it leads by example.
It's also,
I think,
an active exploration into what makes a
movie great.
It explores the kind of unique
perspective that a film can gift to the
film goer like a language gifted by
aliens and what kind of brand new world.
That perspective allows us to see.
Hey everybody.
Thanks for watching.
Happy Wednesday and have you been on
time?
Stay to my girlfriend who's sitting
right over there,
even though it's a day late.
I recorded this on Valentine's Day,
so I love you baby.
Anyway,
thank you to squarespace for sponsoring
this video.
If you don't know,
squarespace has beautiful award winning
designer templates for websites for your
business.
So if you're a musician or a restaurant
or whatever,
a squarespace is the perfect all in one
tool for designing a website.
For that,
it's flexible.
The domain names really easy and you
don't have to know coding or anything.
Um,
and if you use the offer code
nerdwriter,
you can get 10 percent off your first
purchase,
which is pretty cool.
Anyway,
thanks guys for that.
And I'll see the rest of you next,
last Wednesday.
I love you baby.